got to get to this this clip really
shocking came out from project veritas a
connecticut public schools assistant
principal
was caught on camera discriminating
against hiring catholics because he says
if you hire catholics then they're not
going to indoctrinate the kids well
enough and they're not going to churn
out democrat voters in the future
so if you find out if someone is
catholic
i think the questions that we might
start including is something about
transgender students
i don't think kids
have a good knowledge to that decision
[Music]
i can't
tell them i'm not interviewing you
because you're older i just don't get to
[Music]
sometimes doesn't matter what they think
about you know if they think about it in
a logical progressive way
like
so you kind of like do it on top in a
more liberal way
teachers are actually more savvy
about delivering
a democratic message
really
politics we only want people that are
going to listen to other people who
listen to the people
it wasn't the conservatives on the
supreme court
but it's
little things like that you hope those
little things and then later down the
line
that's it that's what they're going to
do he's saying we don't hire catholics
if someone is a really well-formed
catholic
they're never going to go with the libs
they can they're not going to do it too
much thomas aquinas that's not they're
not so we can't hire them we got to
discriminate against them how are we
going to do that legally we'll ask them
about transgenderism because they know
this is why the lib's one of the reasons
the libs focus so much on transgenderism
because it just tells you everything if
you believe that men can secretly be
women you're a leftist
if you don't believe that you're one of
the bad people you might even be a
catholic but you're certainly you're one
of those bad conservatives you're out if
you're a little bit older you might be
more conservative okay we're not going
to hire you we don't even need to
mention explicit politics we are going
to push this stuff on kids and churn out
democrat voters starting in
kindergarten and you know to this guy's
in this guy's defense
he's acknowledging one basic truth there
is no neutrality here especially in
education there's no neutrality they're
either going to be trained in the
conservative way
or in the leftist way they're going to
be trained in the atheist way or the
christian way the cat the catholic way
maybe is that's what he's really worried
about
it's going to be some kind of training
that's what education is and so yeah
it's illegal for him to do what he's
doing to discriminate against catholics
and conservatives in in the schools
but he's just he's doing a natural thing
he's saying we want a certain type of
education not another type of education
that's maybe conservatives need to start
thinking that way too right now head
over to puretalk.com enter promo code
knowles podcast verizon att t-mobile
these guys take way too much of your
money every month and the way they
justify it is by giving you way more
data than you will ever really need
that's really concerning especially
given the state of our current economy
no matter what the libs tell you we are
in a recession now it's time to hunker
down save some money wherever you can
one of the easiest ways that you can do
that is by looking at your current cell
phone bill are you paying too much money
what's your current bill could be 80
bucks 90 bucks are you paying for way
more data than you need then you should
talk to my friends over at puretalk pure
gives you myriad choices so that you can
choose the data plan that is right for
you whether that's two gigs per month or
an unlimited plan with a mobile hotspot
doesn't matter whatever you want by
switching to pure talk the average
family of four is saving over 75 bucks
per month
customers are realizing they simply do
not need as much data as they thought
plus puretalk makes it easy to find the
right plan for you and your family
they're a veteran-owned company with
customer service team right here in the
united states make the switch okay it's
super easy to do it takes 10 minutes i
am a pure talk customer i love it
fabulous 5g wireless network right now
this month when you switch to puretalk
you pay for one month you get the second
month free i have been endorsing pure
talk for an extremely long time right
now they have never made an offer this
big go to puretalk.com choose your plan
enter promo code knowles podcast for
this special offer that is puretalk.com
code knowles podcast to get your second
month free
greetings exalted nostradamus peace be
upon you
i have a question for you about acting
i've been acting in theater for about
eight years now and i've recently
secured an agent to pursue acting
professionally
however i have some concerns about the
increasingly profane
and obscene and sexual content that you
see in tv and movies these days
and that i may be expected to do or say
things for the camera or on stage that
directly contradict my morals
so i was wondering if if there is any
gray area regarding what you do as an
actor morally speaking because since i'm
only pretending
is it possible to do or say sinful
things while remaining inculpable
because my heart is
in the right place and my intention is
merely to entertain the audience
basically my question is jim caviezel or
mark wahlberg thank you
this is such a good question and i was
just discussing this last night with the
clavins spencer clavin and drew clavin
and
you know spencer and i met we probably
met for the very first time when we were
doing plays and operas and things in
college so
you know we've been thinking about this
question for a long time and i think
it's like the iq bell curve meme
okay
at the really dumb stupid idiot drooling
end of the spectrum you guys are going
to say i don't know actors are kind of
liars and they're doing bad stuff and
that's bad right and then you get into
the middle of the iq bell curve meme and
they say no actually when you're acting
a role it's completely divorced from
your own person and you have no
culpability whatsoever for the things
you're thinking and doing come on it
plays a play and then at the highest end
of the iq bell curve meme i think you go
back to the drooling guy and i think you
say no actually actors are kind you know
there's a reason they weren't allowed in
restaurants for a lot of history there's
a reason they were lumped together with
criminals and prostitutes for most of
history there's a reason that the church
took a pretty hard line against acting
as a profession
and the theater broadly for you know
roughly
14 to 1600 years
because
it is a complicated question
and it's a little bit different when you
are a writer
and you write a
story about
i don't know a rape and a murder and uh
terrorism and a serial killer
you are your mind is wandering in
certain places you are sometimes opening
up wounds you're sometimes indulging
kind of disordered thoughts and even
desires then you put it on paper and
that's that it's an action only of the
mind
when you are
attending a play or watching a movie
you are allowing yourself to indulge
certain desires
and things that could be disordered and
not great for your soul but again it's
it is just in the mind it's not really
in the body when you are acting uniquely
when you are acting you are putting all
of this into your body
and so you are really doing it and
because we're incarnate creatures that
affects us this is especially true
after what is colloquially referred to
as method acting comes about
which is all comes out of freud you have
freud
come about you have the kind of
psychological revolution of the
19th century late 19th century and early
20th century then in russia you have the
stanislavski system which is the first
kind of method acting where where
stanislavski the director of the moscow
art theater says we're no longer going
to have representational stilted acting
where you just you're basically like a
glorified mime no you're going to
develop the inner life of your character
and you're going to live truthfully in
imaginary circumstances out of that then
in new york you get the group theater
the group theater is
uh people like lee strasberg stella
adler sanford meister udahog and all
these people and they're all a bunch of
communists and they're all really into
this stuff where your your
inner life is it's all coming from the
subconscious and they all get kind of
they all do a lot of weird stuff lee
strasberg uh one of the great acting
teachers in new york won't name him uh
but he refer he referred to lee
strasberg as a pervert and a voyeur and
a lot of it you know when people really
get into the method or any of this
the meisner technique or the adler
technique sometimes it really can mess
you up okay
actors are all completely insane and it
it really can warp your
soul and your body so i'm not going to
give you the easy answer of hey don't
worry about it it's okay
you know no big deal a place to play no
you have to be very careful about it
because it is your mind and it is your
soul and it is your body i'm glad you
liked that clip now
ring that bell subscribe we've hit a
million subscribers that's great i want
to hit a billion so head on over right
now ring that bell get the notifications
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you